he has done so many accomplishments from
being a rescue diver to being like a
rescue forest ranger i might have making
that part up a little bit but you help
rescue people somehow um he rode a 100
mile bike ride on a folding bike
which
yeah
do you know how hard that is to do
he also ran like a like a a bike race
around a park in new york city as a
folding bike le mans starts you had to
run to the bike and unfold the bike take
it apart and like set it up it was
amazing uh so many cool accolades i can
give to this man i wrote a great book
pandas for everyone which are going to
give away copies of pandas for everyone
actually as soon as he's done speaking
we'll give away a copy of it uh so many
things i want to say to it that say to
dan
he was my student 10 years ago
and now has now he's a lecturer has his
phd everyone please welcome dan to the
stage
um so today i want to talk about
sort of like what i've learned doing a
dissertation project
so it's really a big
analysis work and generating reports and
projects and then sort of like what i've
done and what i would sort of improve
upon it
and so i want to share those results
with you
first i would like to acknowledge that
we are currently located on the native
lands of the muncie lanape people
which is
just north of us is also the peoples of
the
wapner and to the east of us is canarsie
and then the work that i did was
actually in southwest virginia in
roanoke uh because i went to school in
virginia tech and those belong to the
native people of the toledo tribe
and so also i would also like to give
thanks to
beatriz in the our ladies community for
helping create this quarto template
that i'm using today
so yeah like jared said i finally
graduated
for the longest time it was every single
year that the nyr conference ran was
another reminder that i had to go
graduate so i finally did it
back in december
and so yes so i'm currently a
teaching postdoc at the university of
british columbia i also work as a data
science educator at our studio i helped
jared with stuff and wrote some things
and i've also
just recently sort of like gave up my
duties working with the carpentry just
because there's too many things to do
but yeah so today again i want to talk
about combining analysis work with
reports and presentations
and so this is a topic i talk a lot
about so you can look through previous
talks that i've given
i also teach a lot of this content
pretty often
and i really want to just go about how
would you go
work
with these best practices given that you
actually have like constraints like time
constraints or other types of
constraints and then like how can you
set things up so you can make
incremental improvements and increment
and learn incrementally
and so
yes there's going to be a lot of things
that you may or may not be doing right
now but treat it as like hey the next
time you try a new project like time box
you're learning and try that out and
then if it doesn't work within like 30
minutes to an hour like just give up and
do your own thing but at least you gave
it a shot
so back in 2019 i think it was like the
last time i spoke in front of live
people
i gave a talk about building
reproducible and replicable projects
and
this is important because when you have
your analysis work that is reproducible
and set up in a replicable way
you can build in more features you can
move to like other compute servers and
it makes a little bit easier to work
with other people
and so first let's talk about the
analysis project structure
for those who are academics you can
actually reference this paper
by william noble that really outlines
hey if you really need to
work on analysis here's some folder
structure if you don't know where to
start
and instead and the main parts is you
have like a folder for data you have a
folder for documentation things and then
a folder for results and then
code
so that can either be
source code or like a binary depending
on what language you work in but those
are like the main general folders that
you should start off with um when you do
your work
and so in my dissertation i did
something pretty similar this is all in
one giant folder but there were really
two parts to it so on the left hand side
you see all of the files and folder
structures used for like the project
itself and packaging and then there's
also the series of folders i use for
like the actual bits for the analysis
and so you can see like i have an
analysis folder it's broken down into
sections
there's a way to call those analysis
full scripts
my data is getting loaded from somewhere
and then i have like outputs of various
things
being saved out
and so the first thing is knowing how to
name things so there's these two
resources one by carl and one by jenny
and essentially you want to make sure
that your
files are machine readable but also
human readable but then also plays well
with like natural sorting and so mainly
with dates like please use iso 8601 and
then the other thing that jenny bryan
has said that
really only get as complex with your
naming as
like
as complicated as the regular expression
you're able to write
because you can use your file names to
sort of you can parse out information
later on and you kind of don't want to
write like this gnarly regex thing that
you don't really understand
and so that's naming your files but then
you want to actually go and create a
project so the way you do that in
rstudio is in the top right corner you
can click on the little
r in a box
icon and go to new project and what that
allows you to do in combination with a
package called here
is it will find the starting point of
your pa of your project
and so that means that as your project
evolves and you have to move scripts
into subfolders and stuff and stuff like
that you don't have to like go back to
that part in your file and like change
the data path because if your data isn't
moving around and you're just moving
around your r scripts that's totally
fine it will be able to find it
and then the other thing that's really
useful is
because i'm working in a git environment
i'm only really committing like the
final artifacts that i really need so
like i'll have like
exploratory plots and all of that but
the ones that i'm actually using for a
presentation or a report i will
explicitly save those out using like
something like gg save and then actually
commit those into the repository
so next so that is like the setup of the
project what about the actual like
underlying code bits um so one thing
that i sort of realized
people talk about testing code all the
time in a lot of these like workflow
talks but i felt that like since i'm
really just doing analysis work it kind
of doesn't make sense like if i'm
writing a function and all this function
is doing is selecting columns and
filtering rows do i really need to write
a unit test for this
probably not
um
and so but i still end up testing my
work and i use stuff like stop if not or
the test that package or the checkmate
package to still make sure that like
things are doing as i think like
hopefully the way that they're working
um but the that is the difference
between like me being an analyst versus
me writing like research software
and so in your own code what you can do
is for example use stop if not and if
some value is equal to the value that
you're testing then nothing happens so
just your code would just silently just
keep running but if it meets a condition
that isn't true then your code will
actually stop and halt and so that's
like a way where you can sort of pretend
that you're unit testing it'll set it up
for a unit test later on
but this is still some way that you can
still check your work
even if you're working with your own
like types of functions and this is also
really useful if you're reading like
sensor data and you know that like this
is supposed to be 300 rows and 300
columns you can write a test for that
just to make sure that your data is
being read incorrectly
the other thing that's really useful is
pinning your package versions so there
is a library out of our studio called rm
and the way you use this is in rm view
called init on your package it creates
this rm lock file and all you need to do
is say rm snapshot and all the packages
you have installed
will get put into this
lock file
and then if you migrate to another
machine or something else
since you already checked in that lock
file all you need to do is run rn
restore and it'll sort of save all of
those package versions back into your
environment so that's another way where
you can at least make sure that if
you're working on like two different
laptops or two different systems you
have the same exact version of your
packages
the thing that i would actually improve
about the work that i ended up doing so
i do end up making all of these random
source calls
but i had set up my project in like in
our package format i just never used it
so for me i ended up using the here
library to find all of my scripts and
then at the top of my
a lot of my analysis scripts i was just
sourcing this stuff
but there's an actually i learned that
there's an actual better way of doing
this
and so the way you would do this or the
way i would improve upon that is
actually go and make the description
file since i already have the capital r
folder and really all you need to do is
if you put in the top of a description
file type is project
then at the top of my code all i needed
to run is package load load all and
would have like sourced everything
for me
and that makes it really nice or even
nicer when i am
trying to tweak a function all i need to
write is run is package load all
and then all of the changes i made for
that function just got loaded up i don't
have to like even find which file or
which line to source it sort of just
treats it like a package without
actually setting it up as a package for
cran
the other thing that's
really new and i haven't even looked
into this yet but if you if you're on a
windows machine you would have noticed
that like our if you install multiple
versions of r there's like a way for you
to actually switch r versions on a
windows machine
um
if you're on a mac there was there is an
application called r switch that allows
you to do that as well but there is this
new application called rig
and essentially this is the
operating system agnostic way of
installing multiple versions of r on
your computer so you can toggle between
our 4.2 and r3. i don't know 7
4.0 et cetera et cetera so this is
another
way of saying that like hey i've version
pinned not just my packages but the
actual version of r as well
and then the other thing that i did was
with my build environment so what i
ended up doing because all of my stuff
was in our scripts i was i just had one
r script that was sort of running the
knitter commands and knit everything or
calling those scripts
it's kind it kind of worked for my use
case i i didn't mind just running my
entire analysis every single time i like
needed all my figures updated or some
set of figures updated um it took like
30 seconds so i didn't really care too
much
but the way if i really and i should
have spent the time learning this during
during my dissertation work but i would
have really looked into um this targets
package where it would actually formally
um
where i would formally track how the
objects are dependent on one another so
like this figure relies on this script
and this grip relies on this cleaning
script et cetera et cetera and then i
would run targets and it would figure
out like which actual script does it
need to run to generate the figure so it
didn't have to like run everything it'll
be a little bit smart about like only
run the parts that need to be run
because those are the only scripts that
you've changed
um i also
in general i tend towards leaning
towards using uh an application called
make
and essentially it's doing the same
thing except it's not specific to r
and there was a talk about make from
that talk that i have linked
that you can look up
later so next the other thing is that
dissertation has a bunch of different
components to it so what do you do about
all of those other related projects
in this overall
project so
for example in my work i had at least
eight totally separate repositories and
i needed a way to keep track of all of
them
and so yes you can have a heuristic
where you're like okay every time you
clone down the repository make sure it's
all in the same folder
that works um but it still means that
like i have to like go make sure i hunt
down like all seven or eight of these
links and then make sure that i clone
them in all in the same place etc etc
so like i had a whole series of projects
around that were booked down based so
this was before quarto came out and was
a thing
um i had you know certain projects that
were mixed and weren't using uh
reproducible format so like my irb
application was this word doc that i had
to submit some of my presentations were
on google slides
so i just downloaded those
into a repository as a pdf just so i had
them but they weren't really in a
reproducible format
and then the other issue that i had was
um
finding a way to collaborate with and
without git so mainly with my actual
dissertation writing um
i ended up pushing up to my git repo and
then i had my advisor
look at the repository since it was
synced up with overleaf and so like all
of her comments were through overleaf
and i had to do the work of like
synchronizing all of that work down and
i don't really know of a great way to
like other than using overleaf
where you can like coordinate on writing
like a technical document
where one of those party members doesn't
know how to use like git as a version
control system but this is sort of like
my work around
around all of that
as you are
writing these like really complicated
documents one of the things i i would
highly suggest you figure out at the
very beginning is learn how to use the
child documents and whatever system
you're using and so for me my whole
dissertation was written in latex and so
like i had this main text file
and using
sub files you can create a link to
another file
and then in that link so this was in the
introduction chapter of my dissertation
and then so in the introduction chapter
it had a whole bunch of other
subsections to it and each of those
subsections was linked to another file
and the reason for this was again i had
this weird like overleaf integration
thing going on and so if anything
horribly happened it only happened in
like
the three paragraphs of writing that was
going on and i also didn't have to
scroll down through like thousands and
thousands of lines when i just needed to
edit a certain thing so child documents
does end up making the actual project
repository look more complex but it's
just so much more
like usable and like
yeah i'll leave it at that um it's a lot
more usable
um just because you're not staring at
like hundreds and thousands of lines of
like just straight up text
and then so for something as complicated
as like compiling a latex document this
is where i use a make file
and one of the things that i put into my
make file is i by default make defines a
of command called all
and then what i'd write in my make files
is i put in two hashes the name of the
command and then like some simple
description
and then
with the power of grep and said
what this allows me to do when i set up
my makefile is when i run the command
make it sort of just dumps out like
here's a little shortcut of all the
things you can run and this helps you
from you know catting this file and
trying to figure out what are all the
things that i can do
if you leave like these little
breadcrumbs for yourself
you can get like a nice little output
like this and this is this helps a lot
when you're like you know sort of
panicked writing um and trying to just
get things working um towards the end
and so what i would actually change is
since quarto is now a thing and it
allows you to sort of use
latex templates that would be the next
thing that i would try to look into
i had thought about using
knitter and latex like the rnw files but
i still have to synchronize everything
with overleaf because my just so i can
get feedback from my advisor and so like
i don't know if that's still like a
great idea mainly because like i still
had to do that overleaf integration
but if i didn't that's what i would
actually do because then i would
actually be able to load up those
resources in r into like the actual tech
document
so i talked about all the different uh
repositories that i had and so that was
the other big challenge of like how do
you actually go and keep all of these
pieces together
and so
the way that i ended up using this
was through
using some part of git called git sub
modules
and so one of the rules around using git
is don't nest your git repositories like
if you click clone or init something
nowhere in any of those subfolders
should you get clone or init another
folder
but git sub module sort of allows you to
have like sort of have that feature
available to you
and so what i ended up doing was i had
this big giant project called my
dissertation and then in a subfolder i
had all of my other git repositories
and then so for example my analysis
uh repository which was its own totally
separate git repo
i had it
and
i was able to access it as if it was
just a regular subfolder and it was
treated as two totally separate git
repositories and so that's what git sub
modules allow you to do
i'm not going to go over how to use git
sub modules but essentially each sub
module is its own repository that you
probably if you've no git and github
just treat it like a regular repository
the only difference is when you commit
and push to github you have to go back
to the parent repository and then do
another round of adding and committing
and that second round of adding
committing is all it's doing is keeping
track of like the actual commits
that it should reference to in the sub
module
but it
the other way you can think about it is
when you use git sub modules the mental
model kind of is like nested git
repositories and you just have to track
the one inside totally separate from the
one outside but you have to do it twice
and so if you look at the actual parent
repository it will look like this on
github and you'll see that it's really
only tracking like the last get state
like that's why you have to make this
separate commit on the parent repository
but inside is totally normal
and you can just treat it as if you
weren't working in a git repository and
that's really nice but now the benefit
is i can clone down one repository and
all eight repositories can come down
with it and i can rely on that um
relationship between those subfolders if
i needed to
and then the last thing was the actual
like experiments some of the experiments
that i ran
um so in short i would really like so i
ran an experiment that relied on uh
shiny
but i sort of like
out of time like sort of just did
something really janky with it
but if i were to do that part over there
is this library called shiny surveys
where you can actually use shiny to
administer and give out surveys and so
and what that also allows you to do is
you can build in like a randomization
process in there so like people can come
to the app put in an id number and then
they get randomized to something and
then you can administer your survey that
way and i would have done i should have
done things that way except for me i
just ended up like as people were coming
into the workshop to take the survey i
would like note i would note their names
and then i would do the randomization
for them and then give them back their
ids and it was like this whole like mess
that took like an insane amount of time
in the beginning so that's something
that i definitely would have uh
worked on better
so in sum what i would have changed is i
would make a description file and put in
that type equals project use rig to
manage multiple versions of r since
other things i had other projects going
on
targets and a make file i should
probably have used those a little bit
more but i didn't
quarto is now a really cool thing like
this presentation's written in quarto
and i really want to be able to
explore that more and then shiny surveys
so
with that thanks
[Applause]
you